by 2030 the European Union aims to
reduce co2 emissions in road freight
transport by thirty percent compared to
two thousand five levels truck
manufacturers can't meet this challenge
solely by improving their engines
Mercedes and some German logistics firms
have launched a project called
efficiency rum it carries out road tests
not only of the tractor unit but of the
truck as a whole system components
already on the market were used to
optimize various aspects of current
actress semi-trailer trucks
the Allanson Wolfgang Bernhardt head of
Daimler's truck division says the trials
concentrated on the tractor units
trailers and tires all of the tractors
were equipped with predictive power
train control tires with low rolling
resistance and trailers with aerodynamic
side panels the efficiency run was
accompanied by the independent vehicle
testing organization DEKRA its
specialists not only rode along on the
test drives they also define the test
conditions and supervise the measuring
buddies employee kammath d'cruz managing
director Dan snyman says the aim was to
test the combined effects of three
measures in actual road traffic and to
come up with reproducible results serve
up with monsta x it's of a glass bar and
I gave nissenbaum the motto of the
efficiency run was everything as close
to the real world as possible three
leading shipping companies DB schenker
logistics elf line and josefina each
provided a semi truck from their fleet
for a week of test runs under realistic
conditions and direct comparison the
shipping companies conventional trucks
were pitted against Mercedes vehicles
optimized for the purpose to make for a
fair comparison all the trucks were
loaded in exactly the same way
as his phone helplines managing director
go to get offline sites the firm's aim
to keep innovating for the future
including reducing fuel consumption elf
line has achieved fuel savings of almost
twenty percent in recent years thirty
percent of the total expenses of truck
ownership are fuel costs so a twenty
percent reduction means huge savings any
measure reducing fuel consumption
eventually pays for itself to achieve
reliable test results the test trucks
are refueled under supervision from the
same calibrated fuel truck that ensures
the same quality of fuel at the same
temperature for each vehicle most of the
fuel is first pumped into the fuel tank
with the last leader from a measuring
cylinder then a scale measures the
vehicles weight complete and by
individual axle
the elf line company is taking part in
the tests with an extra-long truck
Mercedes has also ecologically optimized
such a semi with trailer extra-long
trucks are advantageous for transporting
large volumes with relatively low weight
in terms of transport capacity to
extra-long trucks of the equivalent of
three conventional semi trucks that
alone is enough to improve co2 emissions
in this test the optimizations that
Mercedes carried out on it struck
reduced emissions by up to fourteen
percent even the experts were surprised
as hot on the deck from manager says he
didn't expect such dramatic results
maybe five or ten percent but nothing in
the double digits this clear results was
a very pleasant surprise Russian
unnecessary positive da give mr. von
Ewald Kaiser head of Schenker's land
transport division says its test truck
consumed twelve percent less fuel which
also means a reduction in co2 emissions
clinical geodes biosketch to lessen the
efficiency run has shown that readily
available technology can reduce co2
emissions but there is still plenty to
do via vallen at this nonsense Wolfgang
ban heart wants to continue working with
the shipping companies to improve tires
to reduce co2 emissions but also so they
last longer and cost less he also has as
I i'm saving money through joint
purchasing PPC Alice was Daimler will
also offer trucks with predictive power
train control and it wants to make its
aerodynamic panels more robust for
everyday use without sacrificing
efficiency people are saying about this
in moment on the elf line manager is
happy about the course being set and
praises Daimler for the steps it is
taken he envisions hybridizing the truck
considering how much energy is lost when
a 40 ton vehicle rolls down a mountain
using the brakes frequently and hard
that energy needs to be recaptured for
use in the next uphill stretch
so there are additional possibilities to
improving the efficiency of
long-distance truck hauling Mercedes
approach of regarding semi trucks as a
whole integrated system is promising
trucks with lower emissions would be
better for everyone shipping companies
would save fuel and money and the
environment would profit too why didn't
anyone think of this before